let's talk about the fight over the
south china sea
it's rich in oil and gas there are loads
of fish
and the shipping lanes are some of the
busiest in the world
china wants control of it
but other countries say they have rights
to it too
and the americans well they have trade
routes through their worth
hundreds of billions of dollars the us
has been committed
to the idea of freedom of the seas
and nowhere is that under greater threat
than in the south china sea
so what's behind china's claim over
these waters why won't it share
and could it all lead to war
[Music]
china has been a land-based power for
millennia so it's never had
much of a navy not like the colonial
powers nor has china needed one
until now today china wants to be a
naval force across
two oceans the indian and the pacific
that's to make sure it can trade with
the rest of the world
and get enough oil and gas to drive its
economy
and to do that beijing wants to control
the south china sea
but there's a lot of competition taiwan
for one claims many of the same rights
that china does
then there's vietnam the philippines
malaysia and brunei
they want to protect their turf whether
it's rights to islands
seabed oil or fishing grounds
indonesia's in there too
and the americans they want to protect
those valuable shipping lanes
so no shortage of players the question
is
how is this all going to be resolved
there are three futures for the south
tennessee the one that
it looks headed toward now is of course
china will just get south east asian
countries
to sigh and accept its claims the one
that everybody really wants to avoid is
a conflict
and then there's the third option which
involves pushing some kind of compromise
between
china and its neighbors countries like
taiwan and others that are members of
asean
have tried but no one expects that to go
anywhere
anytime soon because china knows what it
wants
and has been working towards that for a
long time
we're talking about china's nine dash
line back in 1929 the chinese took a
bunch of
old british sailing charts and told
cartographers to draw china's borders
one of them drew nine dashes around the
entire south china sea
and as far as the chinese were concerned
that was that
over the last 70 plus years the line's
taken on a life of its own and
in beijing at least the meaning has
steadily expanded so that today
china's not just claiming the islands
inside it it's claiming all the waters
all the seabed all the airspace
so then in 2013 china added a tenth line
to take in taiwan
its appetite seems to be growing it's
easy enough to understand
why china wants control when you look at
the numbers around
40 percent of the world's liquefied
natural gas passes
through the south china sea from the
gulf through the indian
ocean and onto places like china the
amount of trade that sails through there
is worth three trillion dollars a year
one third of the world total
we am able to control this waterway what
we normally call the sea lions of
communication is extremely important for
china
so there's an expression in latin that
goes if you want peace
prepare for war now china has no
immediate interest in war
but it wants to ensure its access to the
south china sea
if it comes to that in the west the main
shipping lane from the indian ocean
narrows to just
three kilometers and it's surrounded by
american allies
in the east there's taiwan which has
tons of american weapons
and could block china from getting to
the pacific so to help stake its
territorial claim
china has planted its flag on contested
islands that are
in those waterways
in the paracels china's built a bunch of
outposts
while in the spratlys it's added over 13
square kilometers of reclaimed land
since 2013
and turned them into military bases the
militarization of the south china sea
has grown
rapidly over the last five six seven
years it has come to a point where
it's unacceptable for united states it
may be unacceptable to the americans
but neither the obama nor the trump
administrations are seen to have
accomplished much
the us's main way of asserting
navigational rights and freedoms
is having its navy sail through the
south china sea
it also conducts military exercises in
the region sometimes with warships from
france japan and australia in the bay of
bengal
in july things got a bit hairy the
chinese and americans both
held naval exercises in the south china
sea worsening tensions between china
and the united states the u.s sailed in
with two aircraft carrier strike groups
the first time washington sent two
carriers for drills
in the area since 2014. and the chinese
accused the americans of escalating
things before the u.s elections the
trump team gave it
one last shot with mixed results
[Music]
don't let the chinese communist party
walk over us
you should have confidence that america
will
what everyone's been trying to do is get
china to obey the law
namely the un convention on the law of
the sea
the law establishes what are called
exclusive economic zones
these extend 200 nautical miles out from
the country's coastline
regardless of whether it's the mainland
or an island and china signed up to that
law
all of the world came together including
china
in the 1970s and negotiated the current
regime of maritime law
which says everybody gets the same set
of maritime claims
china's claims don't fit within that
framework
so the philippines did the only thing it
could it took china to court
one of the big issues was fishing rights
for millions of filipinos living in
coastal
communities like this one food security
is at the heart
of the south china sea dispute in 2013
the philippines argued that china had no
right to the scarborough shoal
it filed a case against the chinese with
an international tribunal at the hague
judges ended up siding with the
philippines remember china's territorial
claim based on that nine-dash line
well in 2016 the court concluded that
it's invalid
when after china lost a landmark
arbitration case before the philippines
beijing realized that the best way to
divert attention from that and avoid
diplomatic blowback
would be to show some progress since the
1990s
asean that association of south asian
countries has tried to cobble together a
code of conduct for the south china sea
the idea was to control china's
ambitions
china hadn't shown much interest in a
code back then
but after losing the case with the
philippines the chinese started to push
for one
though some in asean questioned china's
motives
honestly and unfortunately i don't think
there is any
fertile ground for reaching an agreement
it's not trying to solve anything
right the code of conduct will not say
who owns what rock
it won't say whose maritime claims go
where
it's meant to manage disputes there's
another problem
not everyone in asean is eager to offend
a country as powerful as china
certain members of the grouping
particularly cambodia but also
laos at times thailand have really no
desire
to irritate china and so this means a
whole heck of a lot to
four of the members five maybe and
almost nothing to the other five
and that's a recipe for no progress
vietnam has repeatedly butted heads with
china over their competing claims
the last time there was a real talk was
in dalat vietnam
and the vietnamese delegation blew up
the whole process because they were so
angry
over recent harassment of oil and gas
operations by china that had gone on at
the same time
so they'll say that there's progress i
would encourage everybody to take that
with a giant grain of salt this year's
asean summit was hosted by vietnam
and a lot of it by video because of the
pandemic but the social distancing
wasn't expected to help delegates reach
any agreements on the south china sea
we expressed serious concern over
ongoing developments that infringe on
the lawful rights
of literal countries the problem with
the south china sea is that it's vast
and the stakes are high
there are a lot of heavily armed
countries defending their interests
there
and china's coast guard as well as
chinese militia using fishing boats
often cause confrontations on the open
sea
many analysts worry about all of that
provoking a military response
from someone but strangely enough the
whole dispute also sort of just bubbles
away
under the radar the south china sea is
so insidious
it is hard to keep attention on it not
just within washington but
all of the other global partners and
allies somebody is always going to be
distracted
or find it not all that important the
chinese see the south china sea as
essential to their survival thing is
it's important to everyone there
that's why this whole dispute isn't
going away but china's been around
for thousands of years if anyone's good
at playing the long game
it's china
as with all our star here episodes this
primer is to get us started
but there's a lot more information out
there to help us understand what's going
on in the south china sea
as always subscribe wherever you're
watching this video and i'll see you
next week